そろそろ午後の部が始まります
浅野長男がスライドを使って午後をくださるとのことです
もう少々お待ちください
はいはい  一郎さん聞こえますか？ はいはい
すみません 午後 スマナサーラ長老
スライドを使って午後を始めるとそうなんですけれども
あの[経典]Sādhu Sādhu Sādhu
はい それでは午後の部分始まります
で まず私がお釈迦様が説法をなさったから我々に役に立っていまして
ご説法なかったらね お釈迦様のような方がいたか
いたんでしょうかということすら我々は知りません
だからブッダの価値はこのありがたさがブッダの言葉にある
そういうことで まあ一つお釈迦様がいろんなポイントで語りますから
あの一つポイントをできるだけ省略して紹介したいと思います
で 一応参考にする経典スライドで映りますけど
講演としては開発してないんです
で まあ昨日十二時半とか一時ぐらいで思い出してくれましたからね
今日はウェーサーカですかということで
それから次の私の話の後で
木野寺専誉さんが全部担当で後半を行います
はい で スライドを出してもらえますかね
はい 今日この経典で使っているのは
これ 何と言いますか 戦いのね
火を消すというね 戦術による勝利
で この今日選んだ経典はこの戦い
戦争のテーマなんです
それでそういう俗世間的なテーマを持っても
ブッダがどう語らぬのかと
まあ戦うなよというのは至って簡単でしょ
そう言ったらはい わかりましたと言って戦うのは普通の人間なんですね
これは俗世間では嘘をつくなよとね
人間が言葉開発した時代から言ってきたでしょ
それはその通りであると
でも今からも嘘つくということで誰もやってないんですよ
だからあれこれやるなかれというよりはね
なんか別な智慧のある人は別な言い方はする
それでこの これにはちょっとしたエピソード使っているんです
お釈迦様こうおっしゃるんです
ブータプッバンビッカヴェデーヴァ suraサンガマサンガムサムサムパブイホールサムパブーサムパサムパビュールホウアオゼ
昔々はデーヴァと神々とアスラという人々とね
戦いがありましたと で
それはインド文化ではヒンドゥー文化でも sura アスラというね
どうしても同じ神みたいんだけど
こいつらはよく戦うんですね
仏教では sura アスラという単語も使うし
デーヴァとアスラという単語も使いますね
デーヴァは直接神という言葉に訳できますしね
で この神っていうのは人間という風な感じの意味なんですよ
ある ある一種の生命体でしょうね
だから唯一の神 唯一の神
私こそ神である 他の神はダメだというふうなことは
このちょっと別な文化で現れた考えで
普段は世界中 世の中で犬もいるし
牛もいるしね 牛といっても一緒じゃないしね
人間もいるしね 人間にとてもいろいろ人間がいるしね
そういう風に神もいるっていう感じでね
それでたくさんいるということで
多種々の神がいるということになります
その中で sura というタイトルのグループと asura というタイトルの
だから何かすごく対立的に違うんですね
英語の言葉で言えば Gods Anti Gods ようなものなんですね
Gods ではなくて Deities and Anti Deities という風な単語なんですね
これは今思い出しちゃったんだけど
西洋でもね 神とサタンがいるんだからね
どちらが力強いかで これようわからんね
だからキリスト教文化の世界でもしぶしぶ作った世界は支配管理しているのはサタンのグループだと
あんまり神に立場がないんですね
で サタンっていうのは人間のことを本当に優しく
人間喜んで楽しく 余計なことをしない
楽しく生活 というような感じで
神はそうじゃなくて えらい厳しくて 「
あれやるな これやるな
やるなよ」とかね 「やるなよ」ばっかしで
[笑い]だから「お前もいるなよ」でいたくなるんですね
[笑い]うるさいよと
サタンは逆に「やれやれ
もういいや やってください」と 「
やってください」と言っちゃうと
やる人が自分で決めるんですよ
やるべきかないかっていうことをね
だからやるかやらないかの自由
フリーダム  ですね とにかくそうやって対立するグループ二つはいるんですね
うーん そこでこのデーヴァとアスラが戦いがありまして
アタゴ ビクヨ エパチテ アスリンド サッカン デーヴァナ ミンダン エタドウチャ
それでこのアスラのボスがウェーパチってっていうんですね
で その人がこの神々の将軍は帝釈天なんです
で 帝釈天にこう言うんですね
で 「我々は言葉で戦いましょう」と
戦争ですけどね だから誰がうるさいか
うるさい人の勝ちっていうことでしょうかね
[笑い]なんか女性の戦いみたいにうるさいんだからね
戦いでは女性は必ず勝つでしょ
別に理屈必要ない ただ喋ればいいんです
もっと声高くすれば 男の声はもう聞こえなくなっちゃいますからね
まあそんなレベルの戦いでもない
この場合は この スバシテーナ ジャヨ 「
見事に語った人に勝利 」
あんた方は負けを認めなくちゃいけないんだと
そのエピソードでも面白いでしょ
頭の良い人 せんせつを言える人
すごい賢い言葉得る人が
その人は勝ちやと ただ人数が多いんだからとか
体力 筋肉あるからといって
それはここで認めてないんです
頭いいか悪いかと 頭いい人は勝利を得るべきやという
はい それでなんのことなく面白いエピソードで
この体力で 武力で俺が偉いっていうことはいかに品のない
人間らしくないっていうことは美しく言ってるでしょうに
このエピソードを始めたところでも
いまだに人間が アメリカが空母とかなんとか船を造ると
一隻造ると 中国は二隻造ると
いかに品がないかと 原子爆弾二つ作ると 「
あ じゃあ私は三つ作るんだよ」と
だから猿 進化してないんです
アメリカですか？ヨーロッパですか？中国？じゃない
猿です 誰もが頭を使って
知識を使って 人間に役に立つ言葉をね
喋って人を管理してないんですよ
例えばギリシアの時代ではアリストテレスとかね
プラトンとかね 昔の哲学者たちがいたでしょうに
今も現代も優れた哲学者たちとかいるでしょうに
そういう人々の言うことはもう印刷して出してもね
大学の図書館で虫が食べてるだけ
虫の栄養 だからこの仏教を提案するのは
そういう哲学者たちがリーダーになるべきだよと
その人はもう年寄りかもしれません
若い人かもしれません
貧乏な人かもしれません
でも すごいしっかり頭よくて
人々にこんな風にやってください
これはこれでしょうというアドバイスできる人がリーダーであるべきですと
いまだにそれは世の中で起きてないんです
一番嘘をつく人は 嘘上手な人は選挙で勝つんです
騙し上手な人は次の大-- アメリカだったら次の大統領になる
そんなふうな人に人間を任せていいんでしょうかと
今 王政ではないんだけどね
それだったらイギリス人かわいそうですね
どんなふうに世界が変わっても
ウィンザー系のバカが王様やらなくちゃあかんだからね
今も機嫌が悪いおっさんですけどね
前の女性おばあちゃんがね
すごくしっかりしましたけどね
みんなに愛されていたしね
今のおっさんの王はもうみんな 「
なんだこいつは？」って感じで
どれほどアホかというと
あの あれ 最近 coronation
何冠マスクというんですか
あれは 戴冠式 戴冠式に身を清めて
白い服を着て座るんです
その上にclothというものをかけて
金銀のした白い服なんですね
あの上にかけるclothがちょっとずれてるんですね
座ったら それずれてるところ
自分でそれを引っ張って整えばいいでしょ？できない
あのおっさんに これ見ながら機嫌が悪い
あ これ あの 下着みたいな服見えるんだから
この冠を あの あの 金属の輪っかを頭につける時でしょ？人の一番大事なところ
それ見ながら 「こういうそれちょっと寄せてまとめたらどうですか？」と
それぐらいのこともできないんだというニュースはあるんですよ
靴のひもが-- ひも抜いたら
自分でしゃがんでそれ結ぶことはできないんです
誰かがやらなくちゃいけないんだそうです
やれやれ その人を-- もしその人は政権
権力を持っていたならば
さようならですね 人生は
[笑い]人間は だから
だからいまだにブッダの教えがいかに先を教えているのかと
我々の総理になる人やらリーダーになる人々や人類を導く人
人類のボスになる人は体力じゃないんだよと
年齢じゃないんだよと
理性のある賢い人 世の中で
すっごい頭のいい人々は
世間は一斉にバカにする
ろくに食べるものもない
[笑い]アリストテレスもそうやって苦労していたんです
やっと生きていたみたいですね
弟子たちはいたんだけど
みんなオタク弟子たちで
あのー 同じグループで
[笑い]はい そういうことで
だからこのエピソ-- これエピソードで簡単にお釈迦様は言うんですね
それもこの アスラのヴェーパチッティさんと帝釈天のサッカ
あれミスターですかね？ミスターサッカでわからないね
まあ一応男性ですけどね
サッカ殿下というんですかね
わからない [笑い]サッカ神
まあサッカは帝釈天という風に訳していますけどね
ヴェーパチッティも王ですね
だから正反対の性格 正反対の生き方していて
で ヴェーパチッティ言うんですね
我々は 日本訳で「善説」という言葉があったんだからね 「
対話で戦いましょう」と提案します
私の書いた文章は間違ってますね
ヴェーパチッティですね
二行目 訂正してください
ヴェーパチッティが提案するんです
ヴェーパチッティ王 アスラ王
善説で いわゆる人間が
か その生命体 誰でもいいんです
実行するべき言葉言うこと
言える人がその人の価値だと
それでヴェーパチッティ王がサッカさんに 「
はい あんた先に言ってください」と
そこでサッ-- 帝釈天が先に賢い言葉を言おうとしなかったんです 「
いいえ あなたは先輩だから 」
プッパデーヴァ 「私たち神になる前にから-- 前からもあなたは神でいたんだからね
先輩だから 先輩からどうぞ」と 「
はい わかりました」と
しょうがないね それで
タイシャク じゃなくてヴェーパチッさんが第一の善説を発表します
賢い言葉 ビヒヨーバーラーパビッジャイヨンノーチャッサパティセーダコタスマーブセーナダンデーナディーローバァランニセーダエーと
なんか花のおかげで見えないんですかね？自分はわからない
[笑い]ん？ [聞き取り不能] それなら十分ですね
他の人見えなくても [笑い]あの
これはコピーペーストした日本訳です
私訳したと あの 冗談でも思わないでください
[笑い]コピーペーストです
まあ私訳したら あの この何言ってるかわけもわからない日本語はかっこいいと思ってるんだから
私はすごい俗っぽい日本語に訳しますからね
人にわからなかったら私は腹が立ちます
ここでいいの 言ってるのは
この頭が悪い連中を 頭が悪い人々
お互いに戦って もうハチャメチャもう破壊の道に行くんだと
無知な連中だから 誰かがそこを制御して抑える人が必要やと
怒鳴って叱って しっかりし-しなさいよと
でなきゃ世の中終わりやと
みんなやりたい放題アホなことやっちゃってね
だから世のために厳しく管理すること
罰を与えること 必要やと
頭がいい人は厳しく相手を抑えて
罰を与えて 制御して管理するんだよと
でないとこの世の中終わりやと
こんな そなた大勢の一般人に自由をあげたらね
例えば日本の政府を あの解散するとしましょう
明日から政府はないと
そうすると日本は大変なことになるんだよと
ならないよ なったことはないんです
じゃあ外国が-から戦略来ないんです
[笑い]だって一人一人責任を持ってるんだからね
海軍がいなくても 海の方に住んでる人々はちょっと見張っている
自己責任で それは海軍がいて
警察がいて  入管がいてて
ない いらない [笑い]まあそれはそれで
このヴェーパチッティを言ってるのは世の中のことで
みんなアホでしょうがないんだと
民は 放っておけば何するかわからないんだと
だから厳しい罰 与えて
制御するべきやと それで世は良くなるんだよというアイデアの偈なんです
で それって至って簡単に誰にでも納得いけることで
今も あの自分の国だったら
自分の国ってないんだけど
生まれたところ  その連中にみんなに嫌われてるんだからね
まあ大丈夫ですけどね
で 政府はそう思ってるんです
人々は無知 テロリスト
ですから 国民にはいかなる権利もあってはならない
国が倒産するまで金盗んだ政権取ってる家族二つ三つあります
我々はこれからも永遠不滅で支配するべきというふうに法律を変えて変えて変えていくんです
こんなことやるなよと
民主主義を守らなきゃ言っちゃうとテロリスト扱いされます
まだその法律は国家に出してないんですけどね
はい それに作家さんが答える
エタデワアハンマンジェバラスサパティセダナン
パランサンクピタンニャッアヨサトウパサンマティ
私思うに これこそが愚か者
愚者の抑止である 大作戦がなんか厳しく否定する
そんなのは馬鹿の哲学やと
ウェパチっていうことはね
あれは馬鹿の哲学ですね
そんな風に言っちゃうと失礼だから
それは愚か無知な人を語る哲学であると
一芸でそれを言うんです
パランサンクピタンニャッアヨサトウパサンマティ
人々が興奮して怒って互いに殺してやるぞと言うと
それ制御する人はすごく落ち着いているんだよと
落ち着いて進まるように
ああ まあちょっとちょっとね
まあそんなこと言うなよと
誰かの肩を持って やっぱりあなたの口が強すぎ
言っちゃうと お前もあいつの連中の肩持ってるでしょうと
じゃなくても落ち着け
人々が興奮して戦いに挑んでるならば
それを落ち着くように
静まるようなことをするべきやと
鞭を持って打つことじゃないんだよと
だからすごい反対の言葉を言ったんですね
で 皆様にもウェパチさんの話は納得いきますでしょう
対策点は  ケンカにケンカが戦争勃発したら
まあ落ち着きなさいよ
お互い様という 生ぬるいね
あれは そんなことではなく
経済制裁するべきや 銀行口座全て停止閉鎖するべきであるとかね
その国の産物は買わないことにしようとかね
輸入輸出禁止しましょうと言って
このそれで勝つんだと思ってるんですね
今の戦争にしてもね 一言落ち着けでしょう
答えは だから爆弾落としたらあれこれそんなこと言ったっても
自分たちもやってるでしょうに
だからせっかく苦労して作った建物やら工場やら農場やらね
それは破壊するんじゃなくて
これ破壊したらあんた方にも悪いでしょうにと
で 戦争すごいお金かかるで
それは国民の福祉のために使いましょう
だから我々の問題は まあどういうふうに問題でしょうかというふうに
この落ち着いて話し合う
そのことをやらせる人がいないんです
だからウクライナ人一人でソ連人二人入れても
お互い戦うだけでしょう
意味がない 誰かが落ち着きなさい
はい あなたの言い分は？はい
わかります はい あなたの言い分は？それであなたの言い分は？これこれは一応理解できますが
これこれはやりすぎ 言いすぎ
あなたの場合もこれこれは理解でき
納得いきますが これこれやりすぎ
だからやりすぎ こちらでこれカット
あなたのやりすぎこれでカットしてここで仲良しなさい
情けない猿みたいに牙をむいて戦うなよという落ち着いた人が必要なんです
だからそれが格好いいやと誰が言うんですか？帝釈天が言うんです
帝釈天って人気ないね
そんなこと言うと そこでヴェーパチさんが答える
エータデーヴァ・ティティッハヤ
ワッジャン・パッサメヴァーサヴァ
ヤダーナム・マニャティー・バーロー
バヤー・ニャーヤン・ティティッハティ
アッジャールーハティ・ドゥンメードー
ゴーヴァ・ビーヨ・パラーイナン
ヴェーパチって言うことは普通の日本語で言えばね
人が興奮して怒ってると
あんた落ち着け 落ち着けって言っても
落ち着いてる 怒っている愚か者たちはこう思いますよと
こいつは怯えていると
だからこれは戦ってやるぞ
殺してやるぞと言っちゃうと
まあ落ち着いている 何も言わない
やっぱり怯えているでしょうと
馬鹿にされるんだよと
ですから ああ こんな腰抜け臆病だからね
徹底的にやっつけようと追っかけてくるんだよと
牛が尾っぽを上げて逃げるんだったら
なおさら追い出すような感じで
牛が尾っぽ上げて逃げるっていうのは怯えてるでしょ
牛は見たことない我々には全然わからないんだけど
インドではね 牛がいますからね
怖くなったらかなり早足で逃げるんで尾っぽを上げて
普段牛の尾っぽは落ちてますけどね
怯えたら 怖くなったら上がるんです
だから牛が逃げると面白くて
もっと怖がらせて追い出したくなるんです
ですからヴェーパチさんは忍耐はダメだよと
馬鹿にされますよ 落ち着きましょうと言っちゃうとね
馬鹿にされてなおさら攻撃することになるんだよと
はい 長く乗るんだから
それにやっぱり作者さん答えなくちゃいかんですね
次に作者さんが答えるんです
カマンマンヤトゥアーマワバヤマヤアンティティッカティサダッタパラマンパラマアッタカンチャビーヨナビッジャティ
耐え避け点はなんかちょっと態度取っちゃうんですね
いいよ 別にそう思っても
これは臆病者やと だから向こう怒って戦争に挑んでいるのに
じゃあ落ち着きます あんた腰抜けや
別にいいよ 言われたって
気にしないやと あんた怯えてるでしょ？だから落ち着いて
だから忍耐 だから我慢
忍耐は日本人嫌だから我慢という言葉使ってるでしょ
我慢することは悪行為で
忍耐は善行為です ですから
今日からも我慢してください
それで皆さん同じことでしょうって意味は？と同じじゃないんです
全くないじゃないんです
我慢するということは自分の気持ちがあるんです
自分のアイデンティティがあるんです
それを抑えて抑えていることだから
これ壊れるでしょう 人格が
忍耐っていうのは理解することです
ああ そんなもんだなとかね
例えば雪山に入ったら寒くて
それで我慢する その人は病気になる
で 雪山だから寒いんだからね
直接雪に触れちゃうと凍傷する恐れもありますから
じゃあどうすればいいでしょうかと
何とか何とか まあ葉っぱでも持って体を守ってじっといる
その人は賢いでしょうに
ああ 嫌だ嫌だ 火を起こしたいんだとかね
火を起こせないんですね
雪山の中で だから我慢することは悪行為で
忍耐することは理性の行為で
だって寒いんだからね
ああ寒い 嫌だではなくて
まあちょっと飛び上がったり
あのースクワッティングしたりすると
体を運動するんだから暖かくなりますよとか言って頑張ってそれをやる
それもそれは忍耐 うん
はい まあそんな余計な話をやめましょう
えーとですね ですから
忍耐することこそが最上の勝利であると
殴り合いこと殺し合いじゃないんだと
今の戦争に見ても 忍耐で
まあいいやもう ということになったらすごいかっこいいでしょう
かっこよかったでしょね
いいんじゃなくてね 品のない言葉言って罵り合って人殺しやりやがっちゃって
どちらも損失しかしてないでしょうに
で 殺し合いをやる それでも
ですから 相手に何か 何か非があるかも
例えばウクライナの政治家が何かロシア人のプライド傷つく態度を取ったり
それに乗る ロシアが乗っちゃったんだからね
だから完璧愚か者なんですね
どうそうどうそう言ってから
そんなもので偉大なロシアがめげませんよと
どうぞ批判してくださいと
我々はあなた方に何か助けてほしいことあったら
それでも言ってください
助けてあげますよと言ったら
一日でその問題は解決する
そんな大げさなことじゃないんです
誰かに理性が必要です
だからリーダーになる人
インチキ選挙ででも総理大臣
大統領になる人は無知な人だから
そこでここで仏教のフレーズはカントゥーアビーヨナビジョティ
それは金言として使うフレーズなんです
カントリーというのは忍耐より優れたものはありませんと
一番世の中で人間として優れた性格は忍耐なんです
で 帝釈天はこれでも怒ったでしょうかね
ダラダラと偈を詠うんです
一対一でなくなっちゃったんです
帝釈天に向かってウェーパチッティがね
そんなお前臆病とお前バカやと
帝釈天にバカと言ったんだから
もうガーッと続けて言うんです
言葉をね ヨーハベーバラワーサンとドゥッバラサティティッカティタマーフパラマンカンティニッチャンカマティドゥッバロー
誰かがすごい力がある
権力もある 武器力もある
何でもかんでも体力も何でもかんでもある
体力も知識力も この力ある人がドゥッバラサティティッカティ
そこまで力がない人の過ちは忍耐する
それにもウクライナとロシアがいい例ですよ
ロシアが大きい国で すごい財産がある国で
ウクライナはそれでは大きい国じゃないんです
ほんの小さい国です それでウクライナの人々はちょっと調子に乗りすぎてるんですね
まあ一応経済活動をしっかりやっていて
経済状況はロシアよりも均等で良くなっていくし
ヨーロッパの隣でしょうし
ちょっと調子に乗りすぎちゃったんですね
だからロシアが力強いでしょ
これは黙っていませんよではなくてね
まあまあいいや もうそんなこと言ったっても気にすりゃいいじゃないやと思ったならば
本当に忍耐っていうのはそういうことやと
自分が力強いのに 力のない人の過ちを気にしないで忍耐をする
殴れますよ でも殴りません
撃てますよ でも撃ちません
国全体潰そうと思ったら一発で潰せますよ
爆弾落として ちっちゃな小型な原子爆弾でも落としちゃえば十分だからね
やらない ということがすっごい忍耐
本物の忍耐である なぜならば
弱い人はずっと我慢していますよ
世の中で 例えば国の経済的な力ない人々は
収入ない人々はすーっと我慢しているんです
忍耐しているんです 気に入ってる服があっても買えない
食べたい美味しい食べ物見えてるけど買えない
お金ないんだから お金のある範囲で生活しましょうと
だからこれ経済的 知識的
どんな時でも弱い人は我慢しています
その時は我慢ではなく忍耐しています
我慢しちゃうとやがて腹が立って潰しに行くんです
革命しようとするんです
だからここで対釈典言うのは
弱い人はずっと忍耐していますよ
だから強い人が忍耐すると
これは本物の忍耐であると
弱い人はしょうがない
仕方がないんだからね
次の偈もそれも対釈典
アバランタンバランアオヤッサバーラーバランバランバラスダマグッタッサパティワッターナヴィッジャティ
そこで私の訳で言えば
力あるんだけど 相手を抑えないで
相手の過ちをあまり気にしないで
いいよいいよという感じでいる
あの無気力さ 本当の力ですよと
例えば誰か国民 例えば昔話でね
一般の庶民の白鳥さんの人が自分の国の王様に「あのおい何やらバカ野郎」と言うと
それは王様の耳に入る
王様はただもうカーストも低い
経済力もなく ただの一般人 「
王様 誰が気に食わんあんなバカがバカ野郎と言ったんだい」と
王様打ち首と言ったらただのバカでしょ
それで王様 「ああ そう言ったんですかね
仕方がないね」とか思ったら
王様だから仕方がないじゃないよ
仕方があるんだから それで王様はなんか無気力に感じるんですね
王様がただ一般人が怒ってもちょっと下がるんだよと
あれ無気力じゃないんだよと
あれが本当の力だよと
許しているんです 相手の力がないと知っているんです
相手が悩んでいると知っているんです
だから王様バカ野郎ぐらい言わせておきましょうと
しかし こういう忍耐する人は
俗世間は腰抜け 力がない
厳しい態度をしない なんだこの人はリーダーとしてふさわしくないとバカ扱いするでしょう
だからバカがそういう偉大なる人をバカ扱いするんだよという意味が対釈典が言っているんです
次の偈は タッセワテーナパピヨヨークッダンパティクッジャティ
クッダンアッパティクッジャントサンガーマンデーティジュッジャヤン
怒った人に対して自分も怒るんだったらなおさら悪いでしょうにと
あんた怒ったでしょ 私は倍怒ってやるぞと
どちらが正しいんですかね
あんた怒っても私は気にしませんよっていうことでしょうに
正しいのは クッダンアッパティクッジャントサンガーマンデーティジュッジャヤン
怒った人に対して怒らないことで
いわゆる許すことかな
ああ こういうことで怒ってるねとかね
理解して はい まあよく分かりましたと
怒らない それでその戦いはそこで終わりだよと
怒ったっていうことは戦いなんですよ
この芸の中で 怒って出てこいと言ってるんです
ただですまないよと言ってるんです
原子爆弾で潰すぞと言ってるんです
だから怒ったとは もう怒って戦いをしようとしてるところで
智慧のある人はそれには怒らないんですね
それでパランサンクピタンナトワヨーサトウパサンマキ
人々はすごく怒って興奮して管理できない状態になってくると
誰かが落ち着いて安穏にいるならば
この人はウビンナンティキッチャターナンアッタノーチャパラッセテ
彼が両者を治療しているんだよと
自分が怒ってないでしょ
だから自分の心を治療しているんです
相手に対して怒ってないでしょ
だから相手の怒りも燃えて消える
相手も治ります なのに人々はそんな人は愚か者やと言うんだよと
怒ったら怒り返さないならば腰抜け
バカと言うんだよと いいや
言われたってまんま愚か者はそう言うんだよと
なぜならば イエダンマッサアコウウィダ
彼らが真理知らないんだよと
本当のこと知らないんだよ
事実知らないんだよと
だから世からバカと言われても気にすることはないんです
あの ということで終わればいいでしょ
私にバカと言うあなたは何者か？って言っちゃうと自分が燃えてるでしょ
真理知らない それで最終的にこれ審判誰がやったか
経典ではっきりはないんだけど
大体お釈迦様が審判 審判役やったような気もしますけど
それでお互いの言葉を場を評価にかけるんです
そこでヴェーパチって間違ってる
帝釈天正しいって話ではないんです
評価するときはヴェーパチっていうのは言葉通りにいけばどんどん戦い
戦い 戦い 戦いの連鎖反応を起こすんだと
戦争は永久的に終わらないんだよと
例えば 人々は王様に対して反対運動をする
王様が厳しく軍隊を動かして
もう殺したり もう逮捕されたり
殴ったり いろんなことをやる
そうするとなんか落ち着いたような気がしますけど
またこれぐらい我々の人殺したんだから
我々の仲間をね 今度は倍力強く攻撃しようということになるんです
だから 厳しい罰で抑えることで怒りを収めるべきという話では
永遠に戦争が続くんだよと
でも帝釈天の言葉から見ると
戦争が勃発するようになっても一回で消えちゃうんだと
だって相手に否定されてないんだからね
向こう落ち着いてるんだから
落ち着いているんだだから向こうが戦争を起こす必要になった原因を解決してあげます
それで戦いは終わるんですよ
だから戦いを終了して安穏
平和になる道を帝釈天の言葉にあるんだから
戦説は帝釈天でありと
したがってこの戦争の価値は帝釈天の価値であると決めたそうです
はい その経典で世にない
でもしかし世にあるべき生き方
ブッダが語っているんです
皆様もこのお話を聞いちゃうと
皆様に馴染みがあるのは
怒ったら怒り 殴ったら殴れっていうことはなんとなく理解しやすいでしょ
でもそれは間違っている道なんです
法則違反なんです なぜなら殴ったら殴り返す
だって相手がまた殴るでしょ
例えば人が三ポイントで怒っている
私に対して 私は零ポイント
相手が三ポイント怒ったんだから
私は三ポイント怒って殴っちゃうと
その人は六ポイントで怒っているでしょ
殴られたらあの三ポイントゼロにならないでしょ
もともと私が悪いと思っていたから
プラス三ポイント怒りでしょ
その上殴ったらもう証拠ありますから
私が悪いと言うために実際の証拠
それで三プラス三 六ポイント起こっているんです
そこで私は六ポイントに怒ってるんだから
それに適したぶん殴りあるんです
そうすると相手がやっぱりこいつは悪人だよと
六ポイントプラス六 十二ポイント怒っているんです
これ自己破壊でしょ これは人間にわからない
バカと言ったらありがとうございますと言えないんです
一回バカと言われたらいるんですよ
日本で人生全部ダメになっちゃうんです
それから自信がなくなって
会社に行けなくなっちゃって
人間関係ももうなんかダラダラになっちゃって
ちょっとの一言葉で なんでありがとうございます言わないんですかね
だから分かりますか？ブッダの教えが必要でしょう
皆様に四パーセント知恵があって
四点知恵があって ブッダから教えれば残り六ポイント入って満点になる
じゃあこれマイナスでしょうに
いまだに世の中では真理の知識理解はないんです
だからAI時代になっても
人工知能時代になっても
ブッダがまあ百万キロ先にいるんです
はい そういうことで だからバカと言われた 「
ありがとうございます
よく発見できましたね」とかね 「
そこまで隠そうとしたのに」とかね
そう言われたら誰が賢いですかね 「
ありがとうございます」と言う人でしょ
あれ いつでもいちいち文句言う人
いつでもケチをつける人いる場合は
我々は嫌悪して逃げたくなるでしょ
逆をやってみてください 「
どうぞどうぞ 一緒にやりましょう
一緒にやりましょう」と 「
あんたがいなかったら困るよ」 「
なんで？」 「だってあんたいつでも何か間違い見つけるでしょ？」
これはすごい役に立ちますよと
私が何やったってあんた何か文句言うでしょ？これは宝物だと
だって自分が気づかないんだから
と言ったら あの人の悪い性格治るし
自分がすごい気持ちいい友達が作ったことにもなるし
それで自分も他も幸福になるし
その道がブッダが教えているんです
その道が人間がすごい嫌いと思っているんです
はい そういうことで 一つポイントを取っても
ブッダがすごい大胆なことを言うんです
でもそれは真理なんです
今日のテーマはこの戦い Conflicts
それは智慧で解決しましょうと
ということで 私の話は以上です
皆様もそのブッダのアドバイスをえ
理解して ちょっと実践してみてください
びっくりしますよ 人生に奇跡が起きます
本当の奇跡が起きます
やってみたら そういうことで
皆さんは毎日奇跡に溢れた
毎日幸福が-- 幸福から幸福へ進む生き方ができますようにと誓願いたしまして
私の話を終了します ありがとうございます
[拍手]なんかしゃべりすぎでしたね
三時に はい 次からあの権力を木下さんに奪われます
えっと 木下さんだけですか？皆さんお上がりいただけますか？はい
木下さんも寂しいんで
皆さん [笑い]ここは歩くと何かめちゃくちゃ軋むんだけど大丈夫かな
壊さないでください  木下さんが前うちに来た時にあの便座壊すかもしれないっていうことで
何キロぐらいから壊れるっていうデータ持ってるらしくて
それ以上のね 体重がおありなんで
でも去年より痩せた感じがありますね
そうでもない？ 見間違いです
[笑い]ありがとうございました
今日は長老ありがとうございました
いろいろと教えていただきました
なんか去年のような厳しいコメントをいただいても
ありがとうございますと切り返せるような
そんなあの お話会を進めていきたいなと思っています
それで今日は  藤本さんにちょっとお話いただけたら嬉しいなと思ってる
大乗仏教の中で最も頭のいい学者さんが藤本さんなんですね
正教寺さん 山口県からいらしていただきました
ちょっとお願いします
今最近はどんなことを研究していらっしゃいますか
そんなお話から伺えたらありがたいと思います
まああの 世の中よく言えば無常なんですけれども
悪く言えば一寸先は闇でございまして
[笑い]何が起こるかわかりませんけれども
あのまあ大乗の坊さんも何か喋れよということで
今日はもうマイク持たせていただきましたので
五十分よりは短く五分ぐらい
ちょっと問題提起みたいなことをお話ししようかなと考えています
私が浄土真宗の坊さんでして
浄土真宗というのは修行は嫌い
でも仏教のことは知りたいから勉強はしたいなという
そういう性格の坊さんが多いんですね
そういう坊さんは仏教学者になりたがりますね
修行するのは嫌 [笑い]でもなんか仏教のことを知りたいなというふうに考えて
ゴソゴソと仏教の本道に入らずに周りでうろうろしているのが真宗の坊さんという感じがしないでもないんですけれども
私もあのいろいろとずっともう六十超えちゃいまして
仏教の勉強をしてきたんですけれども
じゃあそろそろ修行しますかと言ったら
まだ修行したくないんですね
もっと何かないか もっと何かないか
勉強だけすることないかなと考えたら無限にあります
あの四念処経というお経で
修行の体系としてお釈迦様が説かれている中に面白いものがありまして
あの まず体でしょ 体の観察したら悟れますよと
次に受 感覚ですよね 感覚
感覚とこれこれこれって観察してたら悟れますよと
三つ目が心ですよね 心も生滅変化してますから
これこれこれって観察してたら
まあうまくいけば悟れるんですけれどもね
だいたいその辺までが修行の本
本 本 本典？修行のまああの大本ですよ
で 仏教学という学者の世界でも
そこまではなんとか調べよう調べようとするんですね
で 私もそこまで勉強だけはちらちらやってきたので
身受 身まではなんとなく満足したので
修行しなきゃいけないのかな
でも修行したくないなと思ってたら四番目があるんですね
身受身法の法 あのダンマなんですけれども
真理という意味とは限らないんですね
あの  物事全てですよ ひょっとしたら自分の身受身を観察して悟った人が
じゃあ周りの人々の苦しみも助けてあげようかなと
他者のことも四番目の法
ダンマ 物事に含まれるかもしれないし
世界っていうものはこういうものですよと
大きな見方で言えばね
世界はこういうものですよという世界そのものもダンマに入るだろうと私は考えています
そうしますと あのまあ
[笑い]絶対に修行したくなくて
しかも仏教学のテーマで何かできないかなということを最近考えていたもんですから
今年発表するテーマはもう学会で発表するテーマは決まっていて
来年度学会で発表するテーマも決まっていますので
再来年度なんとか発表できないかなと考えているんですが
お釈迦様がね おかしいことをおっしゃいますよね
この世界で私は四番目のブッダですよと
私の前にカッサパブッダがおられて
その前がコーナガマナブッダでしたかね
さらにもうお二人 この世界っていうのがどうもこの宇宙
この地球上のことかもしれないんですね
そうすると え 学校で習ったのは
えっと四百万年ぐらい前に猿からなんとなく人間が出てきて
五 六万年前になんとなくクロマニヨンとかネアンデルタール人とか出てきて
で 一万年ぐらい前 あの氷河期がやっと終わった辺りから石を打ち
撃って あの狩りをしたりね
なんだりして やっと今の文明になりましたよと
ただ一回だけの文明ですよと学校では習うんですけどね
お釈迦様が言うことと合わないんですね
どっちが本当かなと調べたくはなりますね
あの性格悪いですから
何か仏教学で他にないかなと探すんですね
で あのまあ昨日のうちに山口県から東京まで来たんですけど
あの下調べでいろいろと調べ物読みながら来るんですけれども
例えば大昔のプラトンがエジプトの神官から聞いたところによると
一万年ぐらい前にこのギリシャの西
地中海の西 大西洋にアトランティスっていう島があったんだけどね
アトランティスにも人間が住んでて
高度な文明作ってたんだけど
なんか火山が噴火して沈んじゃいましたとか言うんですね
そういうことを調べている仏教学と関係のない学者たちもいっぱいいて
各学会で相手にされません
物理学会でもなんとなく日陰者で
考古学会でも日陰者で
だから私がこういうことを仏教学会でやろうとすると
私もますます日陰者になるでしょうけれども
あっちの民話にこういう話がある
こっちの民話にこういう話があるとか
あっちの文化のあの土器にはこういう模様が描いてあって
こっちの文化の土器にもこういう模様が描いてあってとか
一応調べたりするんですね
みんな大真面目に自分の心のことはさておいてですよ
ダンマ 物事について知りたくて知りたくてたまらない人たちがいろいろとまあ考えるんですね
で 私も仏教について何か知ってみたら面白いんじゃないかなと今考えているところなんです
再来年の話になるでしょうから
まだちょっともうちょっと足掻きますけれども
まあテーラワーダだけでいいよっていう方もおられるかもしれませんけれども
ついでに仏教はお釈迦様は世の中の生老滅のからくり
みんなご存知なんだから
ひょっとしたら物事全部教えておられるかもしれないとお考えになる方おられたら
いろいろお経とかめくってみてください
前のブッダの文明も滅びちゃいまして
お釈迦様のこの今の文明も滅びちゃいますよとお釈迦様はおっしゃってます
しかももう一回だけ文明が復興する可能性もあるんですね
お釈迦様がちらっとおっしゃってますからね
どのような場合でも あのどっかでちらっと見たんですけれども
お釈迦様の言葉としてお経に載っていたんですが
まず仏教が先に滅んで
道徳が滅んで 人間がもう道徳の欠片もない
お互い殺し合い いがみ合いばっかりになったところで
その文明が滅びますよと
ちらっとどこかに書いてあったような気がしますので
我々も今は結構やばいところまで来てますからね
お互いいがみ合ったり
嫌い合ったり ちょうど先生がまさにおっしゃった通りで
人が恨んだり怒ったりするところに一緒に調子に乗ってたら
もうこのまま文明滅んじゃいますからね
あっという間ですよ 原子爆弾まで作ってますからね
そういうことにならないように
せっかくのお釈迦様の悟りの日ですからね
私たちも智慧の目でグッと我慢はしないで忍耐して
物事はこういうものだねと見抜いて
心を成長させていけたらいいんじゃないかなと考えながら頑張っています
ちょうど 分ですね ありがとうございました
ありがとうございます
[拍手]そんな 何て言うんでしょうね
考古学でもなくて なんか面白い分野ですね
そんなこと研究してるお坊さんがいると初めて知りました
変人扱いされてます  ね
皆さん何かご質問とかがありましたら
大乗に限らず 先生が今日ちょうどぴったりの現代にぴったりのことをおっしゃったんですから
何でも質疑応答のコーナーにしていただけると
そうですね  ありがたいような気がします
はい 後ろの方手を挙げていらっしゃいます
マイクをお持ちします
お願いします 本日はそうですね
忍耐と我慢の話が出てたと思うんですけど
自分の中でやっぱり我慢がやっぱ多くなって
やっぱり自分の中のことを振り返ったら思ったんですけど
これから忍耐を増やしていくには
どう心の修行を積んでいけばいいでしょうか
はい 誰か答えてください
忍耐とね 我慢って あの我慢っていうには自我がある
そうです  我慢ね 忍耐は耐え忍ぶという修行に変えるっていう感じでね
はい  あの耐え忍ぶという修行をしてるんだということを
それを楽しんでもらえたら
忍耐が進んでいくと思うけど
私のこの体見てもらうとね
耐え忍ぶということがすごい苦手だなというのがわかるでしょ
いやいや そこは関係ないです
いや 僕どうコメントすればいいんですか？それはノーコメントで
はい ありがとう そんなんで自分の修行として耐え忍ぶんだという
そんな気持ちを持ってもらったらいいんじゃないかな
ありがとうございます
ご回答いただきありがとうございます
いえ とんでもない 他のお坊さんどう？ サードサードサード
サードサードサードってね
いい言葉よね ごまかすにはめちゃくちゃ良さそうじゃない
他にどうですかね 何かご意見とか
我々大乗仏教 しかし浄土真宗さんあんまり修行ないの？ 今から十二年前にスマナサーラ長老の瞑想会をして修行をしたので
西本願寺から追い出しますと追い出されました
ちょっとちょっと触れてはいけないことだったかな
まあ何でもやりますね
修行も好きな人は結構やってるみたいなんですけどね
言い方を例の内観とか言って
心の中を見つめるとか言って
結局わけのわからんことになったりするんですけどね
素直に本場のテーラワーダでやればいいと思うんですけど
やったらまた首ちょんぱになりますからね
命かけてやれと言いたい気持ちはありますけど
いいこと言いました  結構私としてはね
南無阿弥陀仏って好きでね
あの南無阿弥陀仏って一回唱え-一遍上人さんがね
提唱された一遍上人 鎌倉の方にある遊行寺さんね
箱根駅伝とかで有名な遊行寺さんを立ち上げられた一遍上人さんは南無阿弥陀仏と一回唱えたならば
もう自分の悩み忘れてしまって
阿弥陀様にすべて預けてしまってね
この人生をしっかり自分の力で切り開いて生きていきなさいって
そういうことを提唱された方というふうに私は認識してるんですね
ですから 阿弥陀様がいるかどうかは置いておいて
でも一度悩み苦しみを誰でも感じますよね
悩み苦しみ 人生においての様々な問題がありますので
それで南無阿弥陀仏と唱えながら阿弥陀様に預けてしまったならば
この人生 自分で生きることを大切にして
後悔したりね 悔やんだりね
恨んだり そういうことをなくして
真剣に生きることを頑張りましょうというふうなことを提唱されたのが
私は一遍上人さんじゃないかなと思ってるんですね
そういうわけで 私 結構南無阿弥陀仏というのは好きは好きなんです
[笑い]他にはどうですかね
お釈迦様はスザータに乳粥をもらったじゃないですか
乳粥  うんうん はい 乳粥ね
その他にどういったものをもらったりとかしてたとかって有名なものって他にあったりとか
あと あとは何だろう 精進料理の起源とか
いろんなものの起源とか
結構詳しく説教していただいたことあるんですけど
ん？ 起源みたいなものというか
精進料理の起源というか
でも本に載ってるといいですよね
あんまり載ってないから
精進料理のことって お料理大好きだったんで
どう皆さん  スパンサー長老とかどう思われますか？ うん
まあ我々 我々はっていうか
我々精進料理っていうのは肉野菜を食べないっていうかね
生命 生命力が生きてたら生命力が百だとすると
死んだものっていうのは生命力ゼロですよね
我々は生きているので生命力百
例えば百 温度百だとして
死んだものを食べると
魚とか肉とかね 死体を食べると零度のものが体に入るって
そんな考え方なんですね
それで百度のところに零度のものをいきなりちょこっとでも突っ込むと温度が下がる
この下がった部分が元気が枯れるっていう風に
穢れという言い方をするという風に教えられています
それで野菜なんかは植えたらもう一回芽が出てきますのでね
生命力結構強いんだということで
野菜は食べてOKで 生命力ゼロのものは我々の体に入れると
我々自身も元気が枯れてしまう
穢れが生じてしまうので
修行の 特に山の修行なんかの時はね
一週間から十日前からは穢れを起こさない
元気が枯れるってことを起こさないように
肉 魚 そういうものは食べないということになっています
皆さんの方はどうですか
仏教学的に申しますと
インドでは托鉢と托鉢に応じて食べ物を修行者にあげるっていう文化がありますから
いただいたものは何でも食べなさいで
自分のために殺されたんでなければいただいて食べなさいと仏教でも戒律になってるんですけれども
なるほどね  おそらく中国ですね
禅宗なんかが山に入って
自分で畑耕して 自分で料理作って自分で食べるようになったものですから
生き物を殺すことがまずいですからね
植物は一応心はないということになってますから
植物だけ食べましょうと
で 動物は食べないことにしましょうと禅宗が決めましたから
それでなんか中国の影響を受けている日本の仏教では精進料理って言ったら禅宗式の野菜の料理で動物食べませんよとか
ついでにニラとかね ニンニクとか勢力がつくものも食べませんよとかいうことになってるけど
あの勢力つくっていう云々っていうのは仏教の元々とはちょっと違うね
うんうん 中国っていうか
動物食べないっていうのは
殺さないっていうのは偉いんですけどね
うん ニンニク食べないとかいうのはようわからん
口が臭いから男ばっかりの世界でブワーってニンニク
お前いい加減にせえよになるかもしれないから
それで流血を避けるためにやめたっていうのは私の勝手な妄想です
清教おじさんと一緒にラーメン屋行った時
めっちゃニンニク入れてましたもんね
清教おじさん暴露してる
食事に関して 田舎なんかでは法事
法要 お葬儀の時の後にみんなで会食したりする文化っていうのがずっと残ってて
それは近所の人たち お母さん方が集まって
みんなしてお家でお味噌汁作ったり
そういうものご飯炊いたり
おにぎり作ったりして
みんなに振る舞うっていうのがコロナの前まではあったんですよ
それは田舎っていうのも流通があんまりちゃんとしてなくて
うちのおふくろの時代なんかも食パンを食べたのが
見たのがすごい中学生ぐらいになってから初めて食パン見たみたいな
そういう地域 山間部の地域なんで
ご飯を作る時に鍋釜をガスじゃなくて薪とかで作るもんですから
お葬儀頭数がいるんですね
誰が何を運んできて 誰が何を注文して
そうすると各家庭で炊事ができないんですよ
その炊事ができないところを
そのお葬儀の葬家さんにみんなでサポートで集まってるから
そこで一気にお食事を作って
みんなに振る舞って そこでしかご飯食べれないからっていうので
あり合わせのものを食べていくと
そうなってくると 肉魚がね
手に入らない地域っていうのは
肉魚自然と食べなくなっちゃうんですね
お漬物とかお味噌汁とかおにぎりで済まさなくちゃいけないと
そういうようなとこも
あのちょっと日本のね
地域性みたいなんで考えれば
わざと食べないんじゃなくて
食べることができなかったっていうような歴史もあるかもしれないですね
あの木下さんがうちに来た時におしるこ十六杯食べてったっていう
あの 前人未到の記録を立てて
もう誰も破れないっていうね
それ内緒なんだけど  公言します
そんな感じでね 向こう学問僧
こっち僧兵みたいな感じでね
なんか向こう語ってることすごいっすけどね
あの いやいやいやいやいや
他に何かご質問とかありますか？ はい
えっと 今のお食事の話なんですけれども
えっと 前ですね 梵網経でお釈迦様は戒律守ってますよっていうお話で
そのお釈迦様はその木の実は食べない
これは命あるものだから
それから えっと なんだっけな
えっと 木の一杯のてっぺんの芽は摘まないとか
そういうものは召し上がらないけど
死んでるものは あのもう死んじゃってるんだから召し上がるっていうようなことが書いてあったと思って
その木下先生のおっしゃるのとは真逆なんですけれど
どういうふうに理解したらいいんでしょうか
真逆っていうか 我々もやっぱり生き物を殺さないっていう願いがあるから
あの生き物はなるべく避けていこうっていう考え方だったと思うんですよね
言ってみれば死体ですからね
死体腐るだけだから もったいないからいただこうというのは
それはそれも理にかなってるなとは思っています
でもこの 何て言うんでしょうかね
伝統的な 我々日本の伝統的な修験道
山の修行をするような人たちは
そういう穢れ 元気が枯れるっていうことに
すごく山岳修行というのはすごい危ない修行なので
元気が少しでも注意 注力が散漫になるということが非常に嫌っていて
そのやっぱり消化するのに血がね
胃の方に行ってしまうとかいうのが
お肉食べたらそっちの方が血が多く行くとかいうのがあるんじゃないかなと思ってですね
そういうことで気が少しでも逸れるようなことはやってはいけないということで
山岳修行の方ではお肉やお魚とかは食べないということにはなってはいるんですけど
それはそれでね これはこれは
それはそれって感じで理解ちょっとしといていただけたら
別に我々この大乗仏教とテーラワーダ仏教が喧嘩するわけじゃないので
一緒に仲良くね 兄弟のように
まあ我々出来の悪い弟ですからね
そんな感じでね お釈迦様の教えと仲良くしなければいけないと私はいつも思っています
次は藤本先生に質問なんですけども
先ほどのお話と大変興味深く伺いました
ありがとうございます
本当に私もすごくその昔の話には興味があります
それでね そのネアンデルタール人とかいるじゃないですか
で あのホモサピエンス
私たちホモサピエンスっていうけど
血も混ざってるとかいろいろ読むんですけども
で デニソワ人っていう方もいますよね
で 私こう デニソワ人ってアジアですよね
ウラル山脈の洞窟にいて
それでその DNA がフィリピンの方の人にすごく多くあるとかって
それでちょっとポイントがずれてるかもしれないけど
お釈迦様ってもしかしてデニソワ人の血が濃いんじゃなかろうかとか
そういうようなことを考えてるお坊さんとかいらっしゃいませんか
えっと お坊様が火を吹く前に私がちょっと申しますと
あの 情報が足りなすぎますね
デニソワっていうところにいるからデニソワ人って言うし
おフランスのクロマニヨンっていうところの洞窟で出てきたらクロマニヨン人って言うし
ネアンデルタール地方にいたからネアンデルタール人とか言いますけど
それぞれみんな今DNAでわかりますからね
あの骨のガチンコガチンコ成分吸ったらなんとかわかりますから
なんとなくみんなちょっとずつDNAが混ざってたりして混血してますねとか言うでしょ
だから何人何人っていう感じではあんまり考えなくてもいいかなと
一応お釈迦様は人類だけ一種類ですよっておっしゃるんですけど
それにしてはいろいろ違いもかつてはあったみたいだしね
あの東南アジアの島の方で身長一メートルの聖人でね
家もほんともう小さい家とか家の跡とか見つかってて
小人族そういうのはもう確認されてますしね
一方で まあこれ陰謀論ですけど
巨人族についてだけは絶対学会の表には出てきませんしね
どっかで発見されたって言ったらしばらく大騒ぎになるんだけど
続報が出てこない 骨は行方不明
なんか隠してるかもしれないしね
それはまあどうでもいいんですけど
それは陰謀論だから あのお釈迦様の三十二大人相とか見てたら
お釈迦様ちょっと一般人よりは巨人だった可能性高いですしね
確認しようがないんですよね
骨自体が全部出てるわけじゃないですからね
まああのデータたくさん欲しいですね
今まだ本当に断片的で
たまに出てきても 今までの学会の通説と合わなかったら
これは無視しましょうとか処分しましょうとかやってるから
学問の世界もいい加減ですからね
絶対自分の見たいものしか見ないし
ろくなもんじゃないですので
って言ってるから私が嫌われるんですけどね
[笑い] やがてあの わかってくることもあるかもしれません
仏像を調べる人なんかも
今時は仏像のサイズが 三十二大人相のサイズでやってるんだったら
やっぱり一般人よりはちょっとお釈迦様とある一部の人々はちょっと巨人体質だったかなとかね
そんなところまで学問の融合で
仏教学だけじゃなくてね
いろんな分野の人が入ったりしてますので
まあそれはまた追々あれしてください
ありがとうございました
はい えーあの まあ今日の法話で怒らないこと結構だと思うんですが
あの日本人怒らなさすぎだと思うんですね
で ワクチンの問題もあります
私はまあ初め陰謀-陰謀論と言われたけど
徐々にもう物的証拠も出てきています
私も未接種だし 母親にも絶対打たないように言って説得してきたおかげもあって
母親も未接種です で  WHO はもう二回で十分ですよって言ったにも関わらず
六回目を打つと日本は
そしてそれを福島の工場建てる
こういうこともどんどんゴリ押しで進んでますし
これから改憲されて日本がそれこそもう北朝鮮のような独裁国家になる危険性もある
なのに日本人怒らない
そしてもういまだもう初めからもうこれ五類なんですけどね
五類相当なんですけど
もう怖い感染症ないんですけども
マスクをしてるのも日本だけですよね
でも日本人の意識を表すと思います
でも私個人としてはもうこれ改憲されたらもう僕タイかどっかに何か亡命しようと思うんですね
インドとか だからその
これからの日本をですね
どういうふうにこう 何て言うかな
観察していったらいいかっていうか
そういうことをお聞きしたいですけど
私が答えていいですか
あの 先生の今のお話でちょうどあったんですけど
あの 我慢は日本語で書いて我の慢ですからね
最悪ですよね 俺が我慢してやってるとかいう感じで
で あの忍耐の方の言語はカンティとかカマティなんですけど
これは許すとか認めるとかなんですね
あの 幼稚園なんかでよくやらされましたけどね
なんとかちゃん ごめんね
いいよ 許すよと許してもいないのに言葉だけで言わされるんですけど
それはそれで腹が立ってるんですけど
言葉の本当の意味でまあいいやと許すっていうのが
あの忍耐の語源なんですよ
あんたが悪いことやったのはわかってるけれども
私怒ってないよというのが語源ですので
そこに行ってほしいみたいなんですね
仏教の方では 今のお話にもありましたけれども
あの頭が悪くて あるいは力が弱くて訳も分からずに死んじゃうとか
騙されて殺されちゃうということはあり得るんですね
そうじゃなくて 頭が良くて物事を知っているんだけれども
それでもやっぱり打ちなさいで打たされたりとかね
流れで まあこれは私もやんなきゃいけないねでやっちゃって
たまたまそれが毒性の強いものだったら
はい死んじゃいましたっていうこともあり得るんだけれども
ちょうど先生もおっしゃいましたけど
あのソクラテスがまさにそれですからね
本人は大哲人なのに 周りはお付きの人たち
あんまりしっかりしてなくて
毒を飲ませて殺されたんでしたかね
あの悪法もまた法なりと分かった上で
まあ今の世の中これだからこの流れですねと知って許して死ぬんですよね
それになってほしいですね
馬鹿のまんま あるいは知っているんだけど
頭の中怒りでグラグラなんだけれども
力が弱いから悔しい悔しいって死ぬんじゃなくて
ちょっと調べたら ああ
こういうことかと ちょっと進めて道を変えたらどうですか？と言ってみても
もう言うこと聞いてくれないと
じゃあまあ逃げられる限り逃げますけどね
逃げられないんだったら絶対怒らずに
のこぎりで体中切り刻まれても
まあ許しますよと言って死んでいくというのが仏教の勧めるやり方ですからね
私に耐えられるかどうかはまた別の話ですけどね
というわけで 一応あの真珠信法の法のダンマですから
何事もすべて仏教に関わりのないものはないっていうか
心の中が全部世界中のシステムと繋がってるんですからね
知った上で じゃあ私がどう行動しますか？というところで
智慧で そしてまあ忍耐というか
いいよ 許すよと 力強く生きて死んでいきたいなと私は思っています
それ言いたかった [笑い]もうこれで死んでもいい
サドゥサドゥサドゥ やり返し
ありがとうございました
まあ我々もタイには行きたいよね
ちょっと軽く怒ってもらっていいですか？ありがとうございますっていう
さっきの返しね  返し  OK
他に何かご質問とかありますか？ はい
あの 日本の宗派同士の何か関わりとかって最近どんな感じなのかなみたいなお伺いしたいです
なんか知人とかには なんか日本って宗派同士であんまり連携とかしないよねって聞いたんですけど
今日とかいろいろ集まってこう話したりとか
じゃあ仲良さそうでしょ
そうですね 仲いいなみたいな思うんですけど
まあその仏教自体はその元は同じというか
お釈迦様だよね 元はね
そうですね なので初期仏教についてはみんな共通で学べる内容とかだと思うんで
例えばですけど そういった感じで
その 一緒に勉強しようみたいな感じで
宗派関わらず集まってとか
他に関係何かあることで集まってとか
そういったことって何かされたりとかってあるんですか？日本で
我々こう集まってるメンバーは
やっぱりお釈迦様の教えが根本なので
宗派にとらわれずお釈迦様の教えをしっかり学ぼうという仲間なんですね
日本仏教サンガっていう仲間なんです
で まあ私は一方的にみんなめっちゃ仲良いと思ってるんですけどね
皆さんはどう思ってるかちょっとわからないから
ちょっと振ってみますかね
私  藤本さん  あの これまた歴史的に見れば
あの 宗派の教えが各宗派だけのもんだから
まあ各宗派でやってちょうだいよってことで
ただ まあ仏教の何々宗と名乗るからには
仏教共通の教えがあるんだから
そこはまあしっかり学んで
しっかり修行して それを礎にして各宗派やったらどう？という気持ちは私にはあるんですけどね
お釈迦様とお釈迦様の教えも学んでほしいし
日本の伝統のね 各宗派の教えもなんか学んで相互理解進めてほしいですよね
その通りです  はい  ありがとうございます
私はこれで終わりにしよう
あの藤本先生は あの ご本を買ったり
いろいろね ご活躍ですから
もちろん知ってたんですけども
今日は初めて会いました
で まあ思ったより背が高いなとか
そのぐらいしか何とも思ってなかったんですけど
ニコニコしてるんで やっぱりね
仏道を学ぶ方っていうのは
やっぱり心が なんて言うんでしょう
照らされるというかね
そんな印象を受けましたよ
でもさっきさ 飴ペロペロペロペロ舐めながらなんか喋ってなかった？控室で
これから言おうと思って
あの それでですね あの木下さんが
木下善雄さんが まあ一生懸命ね
こうやって企画して いろいろ走り回ってくださっておるっていうのが現状です
その木下さんがこう スマナサーラ長老にお話をまず出して
これやってもいいか やってもいいですかということを許可取って我々やってますんで
まああんまりめちゃくちゃなことはできないなと思うんですけども
それであの藤本先生がね
この午後の部の前に全部私服に着替えてたんですよ
それ言っちゃダメだよ
いいの？ じゃあ言っちゃいました
なんでかっていうと 午後の部はこっちの下の下段に座るっていうのをお聞きしてたんで
先生はまあちょっとね
じゃあ私服に着替えて帰る用意を準備万端してたんですけども
その後 木下さんからやっぱり衣着て下に座ってくれっていうのを言われたんで
ものすごいがっかりして
さっき着替えたばっかりなのにとかって言いながら
散々ぶーたれ出ましたよね
あんまりそこまでは言わないけどね
めっちゃめちゃ汗かいたんで
これ着替えダイエットだなみたいな話をしてたんですよね
だから今日こうやって出会って
初めてお伺いして喋ったり
控室を一つにしたんですけど
何の屈託もなくそういう姿を見せてもらってね
ありがたいなと思って
それでまあついでに言いますけど
さっきあの帯同する時に
後ろの方にここで脱いでた雪駄を全部スタッフの方が後ろに運んでくれたんですよ
それを履いて まあ裸足じゃなく外に出れるなっていう状態でありがたかったんですけど
木下さんが新しい雪駄と取り替えようかなって言いながら外に出たのは私見てますけどね
忍耐でしょ そこは  すいませんでした
ちょっと自分が古い雪駄履いてたもんで
新しいのを見た時にこれ私買ったんだっけな？ってちょっと錯覚しちゃいました
それは私の雪駄を履こうとしてましたからね
でもね あの 何の壁も感じなく
こうやってお付き合いいただいてありがたいなと私は思ってますよ
そうすれば いろいろな地域
住んでいる場所 歴史  それぞれの宗派
それで練り上げられてきたものを勉強させていただけるし
面白い話が聞けるしね
なんか面白く勉強して
そしてウェーサーカのこの法要は楽しくやりなさいっていう風にスマナサーラ長老に過去に言われたことをいつもいつも思い出すんです
ニコニコと楽しんで その怒り憎しみとか
その日は少しストップして
そして仏教の実践 まさしく今この瞬間
一秒一秒が実践してますからね
皆様方 これが自分自身の人生の礎となって
核となって 自分自身を下から輝かせるものになるじゃないですか
そういうような時を過ごしておるんだなと思うとありがたいなと思います
以上です  素晴らしい さあさあさあ
緒方さんどうですか  緒方圭尚と申します
私 日蓮宗です 今日はここから
じゃあちょっと失礼してよろしい
前に出た方がいいですか
恥ずかしかったらそこでもいいですよ
あ でもせっかくだから前に出ます
あの日蓮宗緒方圭尚と申します
よろしくお願いいたします
えーと 私はあの 在家です
自分の実家がお寺というわけではなくて
あの娘が亡くなりまして
それでどうしても何でしょう
自分自身で供養したいなと思って
あの うちの実家が日蓮宗だったので
それでご住職にお願いして
で 推薦になっていただいて
それで現在があります
ですから あの そのそもそもその宗派云々っていうのは全然気にしなくて
で 木下さんとたまたまお会いしたのが
えーと 法要に伺った霊園の控え室で
とても あの 何でしょう
カジュアルに話しかけていただいて
それでこちらでお話を伺って
で ああ こういう考え方もあるんだなと
日蓮宗というのは名前の通り日蓮さんが
あの 何でしょう 主体というか
えーと お釈迦様をもちろん
あの えーと お釈迦様を崇めているんですが
日蓮宗というのはやっぱり南無妙法蓮華経という
その人ではなくて 法をお唱えするというのが日蓮宗です
でも 何でしょう ここに皆さんとお会いして
とても素晴らしい時間を過ごしてます
ただ あの 何でしょう 私が娘を亡くしてから
なんとなくこの仏教で何か救われるんじゃないかなという思いもあったんですけど
なかなか自分の気持ちが収まらず
それでグリーフケアという勉強を三年間
上智大学でしました で
それもあの えーと 礎として
これから何か自分にできることはないかなということで
皆さんから教えを請いながらこれからやっていきたいなと思っています
ですから 全然宗派とか全く関係なく楽しくやっていけたらいいと思います
よろしくお願いいたします
ありがとうございました
じゃあ私の後輩の市川
はい  市川智秀と申します
よろしくお願いします
私やあの先輩の木下善友さんは同じ宗門なんですけども
弘法大師空海が開いた高野山真言宗です
で えーと 私は大学もその卒業したその坊さん学校の専修学院っていうところも全部それでちょっと真言宗とは違うんですけど
修験の山修行もやったりしてるので
法螺貝とか吹くんですが
それも全部先に二倍ぐらいやってらっしゃる方がいて
で その方にお前来いって言われたらはいとイエスしか言えることがないので
ここに来ております こういうご縁をいただいて
長老がおっしゃってたように
あの まあいろいろな宗派があるものの
それは文化だということをおっしゃってたので
例えばこのオレンジ色と黒っても
ちょっと中国経由しただけでこんなに変わっちゃうんですが
日本からすると黒い柱とか白い壁みたいなので
こっちの方が馴染みあるじゃないですか
だから馴染みがある方で学べればいいんじゃないのかなって
私個人は思ってます で
何をじゃあ学べばいいのかなというところは
やはりその仏教に関わっている限りは
自己の向上とか人格の向上というとこがあると思うので
イコールハッピーになりたいというところですので
あのお坊さんに会うと
私はみんなハッピーになりたい人なんだと
本気でハッピーになりたい人なんだっていうふうに思って
仲間意識を勝手に抱いて
すごいすいません いろいろちょっと失礼な感じで
私 自称チャラチャラい坊主みたいな感じになってるので
自称じゃなくてみんなも認めてると思います
はい そんな感じです よろしくお願いします
本当にありがとう 花澤さん
この市川くんっていうのは我々のもうホープですよね
まああれですね やっぱりなくてはならない市川くんですからね
ずっといじられてます
今日もちょっと一番最後に来たら
もうその ああ最後に来たのに何で遅いんだろうとかってね
ずっといじられたんですけどね
そこで今日のあの長老からの学びによると言われた瞬間
ありがとうございますって
言えばいいんですよね
そうですね まああの忍耐と我慢という話の時に
いろいろ控室でのことを駆け巡ったんですけど
みんな忍耐して我慢してたよなみたいな
市川くんだけが忍耐と我慢せずに
言いたいこと言ってた
フリーで自由ですごく心がなんか軽くいてくれてるんで
すごいこっちとしてもありがたいですよ
そういう人がいてくれると
ありがとうございます
花田さん大好きです  やめてやめて
そうですか 公開の告白は良くないですかね
この場での BL 発言はダメです
冗談です 尊敬してます
本気 本気にしないでください
はい まああの そんなんでね
一応いろいろ我々の宗派とかあんまり意識してないです
正直なところ どの方もそうだと思います
そうじゃなくて 日本テーラワーダ仏教協会が主催してくださった
こういう晴れの場に呼ばれて
なんとか協力したいなっていう人だけが来てる状態ですよ
今までも過去何年間も
今まで結構長いこと出てきましたけども
その都度その都度やっぱりそういう意識を持った人たちがなんか助けになればなっていう優しい気持ちや志を持ってつないできたことだと思いますんでね
あんまり肩の荷を下ろしてというか
あんまり肩肘張らずに
心をカチカチにせずに
私なんかできることありますかねみたいな感じで集っていると解釈してもらったら間違いではないと思います
本当ですね そんなんで
あのテーラワーダ仏教さんとね
我々大乗仏教は本当にいつも仲良くしたいし
戦い戦いの場 どっちが優れてるかとかじゃなくて
一緒にお釈迦様の教えを学びたいという
本当に仲間です 皆さんも一緒の仲間と思ってます
だと思いますよ 本当にここに今何かの縁がね
そういうようなものが
心が気持ちが向かなければここにはいないのですから
素晴らしいご縁 まあ日本的に言えば素晴らしいご縁が自分に働いておるなというふうに捉えてもいいと思います
はい ありがとうございます
そんな感じでめちゃくちゃ仲良しです
ありがとうございます
はい  はい  えーと お釈迦様がスリランカの人だったという話があるんですが
スリランカにお釈迦様がおっしゃった四大聖地とか
あと第一結集の時に人のアラハンさんたちが集まったという洞窟
その大きな洞窟のようなものはあるんでしょうか
私 スリランカ行ったことないからなぁ
長老に渡す  あの すごい個人的に最近かね
そういう考え じわじわが出てきて
まだ十分研究されてはないんですね
普通の知識人の世界はまだ気にしてないんです
裏でこそこそいろいろ研究しているんですが
とにかくブッダのストーリーの中で
で かみ合わないところはまあ文化的にありましてね
そういうところはこのスリランカ説ではまあ解決しようとしているしね
例えば第一結集で五百人阿羅漢たち
阿羅漢たちたくさんいるっていうことはスリランカで普通の話ですよ
インドではなかなかデータがないね
本一冊もないんです だから経典全部スリランカにありましたし
膨大な注釈資料もありましたし
で スリランカから世界でいろんなところに仏教を教えて歩きましたしね
だからまあ いろいろそういうギャップがたくさんありますね
私はこの学者たちの方々はね
考古学者やらそういういろんな分野の人々は
この真剣にこれ本当か嘘かとね
調べてほしいなという気持ちはあるんです
まだまだこの裏で隠れてそういうのであって
表向きはこの このマハーワンシャという歴史の書に書いているようなストーリーをみんな信じているんです
まあ以上です あまり言及されてないんです
はい  スリランカ説をなんか私も採用したくなりました
ありがとうございます
そんな説は私初めて知りましたけど
皆さんご存知でした？スリランカ
確かにね スリランカのお坊さんたちが日本にバリバリお釈迦様の教え伝えてくださってますしね
なんとなくね そんな気しますね
先ほどの質問の中で スリランカにお釈迦様のおっしゃった四大聖地に当たるような場所というのは該当するようなところはあるんでしょうか
誕生の地  その方々は全部認定するんで
この場所 これはこれ この生まれた場所とかね
はい あるんですか  だからそのグループがこういう場所
こういう場所と認定するんです
あと第一結集の五百人が集まるような大きな
それもあります  あります
インドに行った時にはなんかすごく狭いとこだったんですけど
そうじゃなくてかなりいいところあります
五百人も入れるような
簡単です  ありがとうございます
ありがとうございます
他に何かご意見とか もうここはざっくばらんにといいますかね
みんなで仲良くする場面ですので
何でも結構ですよ お願いします
もしもし あ 先ほどあの
日本の仏教界はってことを聞いてらしたんですけど
私はえっとね 浄土宗の天岳寺で
天岳寺があの あの お墓があるんですけど
母はあのサイパン島の
十九歳で引き揚げてきて
住むところがなくて 浄土宗の
あのね お寺の観音堂に住まわせていただいて
あの日本の仏教の あの活躍たるや
あの 何て言うか お世話たりや
もう頭が下がります ありがとうございます
皆さんもどこのお寺もそうなさってると思うんですが
まあそれをちょっと言いたかったんで
はい 以上です  ありがとうございます
我々の先輩方が頑張ってくださったということですかね
ね そんなわけで これからもあの日本の仏教とテーラワーダ仏教を一緒に仲良くあの学んでいきたいなと思います
他に何かご意見とかご質問とかありますか？ここでね
誰もいなかったら早く終わったって私が長老に責められるパターンなんですけどね
ちょっと早く終わりすぎですよって言って叱られちゃうんですよね
後ろの方どう？誰か うん
あ すいません 質問したいことがあるんですけども
先ほど藤本先生のお話で
あの 地球の人類上に過去にブッダがいたってお話があったんですけども
それは証拠というものはあるんですか？ まあ証拠に二種類あって
一つは文献上の証拠で
何何文献にこう書いてあるということは事実ですよと
もう一つが物質的な証拠で
穴を掘ってみたら なんとかかんとかが出てきたよというのと
その二種類ある中で 過去仏の話は仏教文献にだけ出てきますから
仏教での文献的事実とは言えるんですけれども
もちろん あの 現在仏のお釈迦様のお経の中にここはカッサパ仏が説法された場所ですよとおっしゃっているようなお経があったり
あのアショーカ王があの仏跡を二百年前のお釈迦様の遺跡をあの探し当てて
もっとデラックスにあのレンガなんかであの検証するためにすごく整えるんですけどね
その中にお釈迦様の遺跡だけじゃなくて
カッサパ仏の遺跡が一箇所か二箇所
コーナガマナ仏の遺跡が一箇所ぐらいあるんですよ
で それアショーカ王が知るわけないので
あのお釈迦様のお経のどこかに書いてあるんですね
ここがあのカッサパ仏が説法されたとこですよとかね
あの そういう意味であの
ただの文献的事実なんですけれども
その場所がここだと同じインドで設定するので
同じこの同じ地球でお釈迦様で四番目ですからね
あの文献的事実としては
なので同じ宇宙だけじゃなくて
同じこの地球のことかなと今は私は考えてるところなんです
だから過去仏の仏教の教えが途絶えて
後にその時代の文明が途絶えて
だいぶ経ってからまた原始人から始めたと
あの仏教の理屈からは考えられるけれども
証拠はなかなかないです
あのアショーカ王の遺跡もコーナガマナ仏
過去仏の遺跡であっても
アショーカ王が遺跡だよって言ってるだけですからね
あの紀元前三百年 二百五十年までしかならないんですね
そういう複雑な問題はあります
物的証拠がなかなかない
あ すいません あ いいですか
インターネットの情報なんで
ちょっと確かなことではないんですけども
デーヴァダッタっていたお坊さんが何かお釈迦様の教団から分派して過去仏を信仰してたみたいな情報が書いてあったんですけども
そういった過去仏を信仰するみたいなことが当時ではなんか当たり前にあったんですかね
うーん デーヴァダッタだけだと思いますけどね
そのグループだけだと思いますけど
だってお釈迦様が現れたんだから
今は亡き過去仏のことを礼拝してもあんまり意味ないんですよね
教えは全く同じだとお経に書いてあります
どのブッダの教えも全く同じで
だったらお釈迦様の教え受けてればいいでしょう
デーヴァダッタはお釈迦様の教えから出ちゃいましたからね
で 過去仏を引き合いに出すんですね
というからくりだろうと私が邪推しています
あ そうですか わかりました
ありがとうございます
他にはどうでしょうか
静止になっちゃった ごめんなさい
[笑い]いらっしゃいませ
ちょうどすいません なんか早く終わっちゃったんですけど
ごめんなさい もう早く終わっちゃったんですけど
ごめんなさい  [マイクのノイズ]はい
あの 早く終わるということで
去年もちょっと手を挙げて
もう二度と手を挙げちゃいけないと思って座ってたんですけれども
えーと 私は自分のことで三月
四月 五月とヴィパッサナー瞑想会
スマナサーラ先生のご指導のヴィパッサナー瞑想会を休んでしまいました
そしたら先生がYouTubeで三月ぐらいの説法の中で
天国と地獄どうするかって
どっちに行くかって そして年取って体がどっかが痛い
腰が痛いとか甘えるんじゃないと
そういう説法をいただいた時に
私はこれは絶対にもう逃げてはいけないと思って今日やってまいりました
明日もあの参ります そんな感じで
もう私たちには火がついてるというか
その生ぬるいことじゃなくて
死を迎える時に 私たちが本当に先生の教えで納得して死んでいけるかと思った時に
今の話を聞いてると あの決してあの
あの あ 今人をこれあの間違ってるとか判断してるなと思って自分に言い聞かせてますので
決して周りを判断して言ってるんじゃないんですけども
先生がいらっしゃら-- 先生はいつももう私いなくなりますよ
早く聞きたいことは聞けという感じでお話なさってるのに
自分が怠けて自分の死を認めなくて生きているっていうことがとてもあの自分でもう辛くて辛くて今日参りました
で 先生が本当にいらっしゃらなくなったら
まあ日本のことを私がすぐ思うんですけど
自分のこともろくにしてないのに
日本のことを思ったりするとなんか悲しく
悲しくなっちゃって 本当に先生がもしいらっしゃらなくったら
この日本はというか 世界はなんかあの終わってしまうような
もうような気がしましてですね
なんかいても立ってもいられなくて手を挙げてしまいました
だから私 あの今いろんな学問的な話のことわからないんですけど
皆お勉強なんですよね
自分もお勉強だったと思うんですけど
自分が死んでいくことを
あと余生少ししかないのに
体がどうとかなんとかって頑張らない自分をもうなんですか
お尻を叩いて今日参りました
だから先生がいらっしゃらなくなった
誰を指導者として 誰をあれをしたらいいのかなと思ったけど
あ 教えてもらったようにヴィパッサナーをやればいいんだなと思って覚悟して帰ります
本当に先生ありがとうございます
そして周りの方のことを非難してるわけじゃないんですね
去年はどうしてもふざけないでよみたいな感じで手を挙げてしまいましたけども
今日はそんなことありません
本当に あの そういう意味です
だから手を挙げました
本当にありがとうございます
はい それではあの祝福の経典を差し上げます
サマンターチャッカワーレースー アッラーガッチャントゥデーヴァター サッダンマムニラージャススナントゥサッガモッ
カダン パリッタサヴァナカーローアヤンバダンター パリッタサヴァナカーローアヤンバダンター パリッタダンマサヴァナカーローアヤンバダンター
ムータスバガワトーアラハトーサッマーサンブンダスナモー[経典の朗読][経典の朗読][仏教経典][仏教経典][仏教経典][経典の朗読][経典の朗読]
えーと
司会の方はマイクから離れないで指示を出していただいた方がいいと思うんですけど
これからあのお坊様に聖水
聖水をあの授与していただきますので
準備ができましたら  お並びいただいて
順に聖水 聖水をいただいてください
皆さん ありがとうございました
今から祝福の糸を巻いていただいて
それから正面にいらしていただいて
正面でお釈迦様礼拝なさってください
その時に我々が着ているこの袈裟
ちょっと後ろから羽織っていただきます
この袈裟をね 羽織った人は
これからもずっと来世にわたって仏縁が
仏縁に恵まれますという
そんな言い伝えが我々大乗仏教にはあるんですね
そういうわけで この袈裟をね
後ろからちょこっとかけさせていただきます
しかもスマナサーラ長老のサインが入っているんですね
実は ここね スマナサーラ長老のサイン入りの袈裟を皆さんちょっと記念に羽織っていただきますのでね
もう間違いないでしょ
もう間違いなく仏縁が来世にわたっても
その次にわたってもついて回ってきますね
そういうわけで もう絶対に幸せになりますのでね
楽しく祝福の糸巻いてもらった後
我々が袈裟をおかけします
それではセッティングどう？OKですか？お坊さんたち大丈夫？じゃあこちらからあのー登っていただいて
順番にね  えっと どのようになさっているんですか？ あ
もう着いた あ そうですか